[MUSIC PLAYING]
JONATHAN GERRISH: It's great
to see so many people here
interested in testing.
My name's Jonathan Gerrish,
and together with my colleague,
Yuki Hamada, we're going to be
presenting a session on testing
APIs today.
So just to get
started, just hands up,
anyone who's written unit tests.
It's not a trick question.
Good.
And what about
integration tests?
You can be honest.
Awesome.
OK, let's get started.
So on Android, there's
two kinds of tests
you might be familiar with.
There's local unit
tests and then
there's instrumentation tests.
So let's start by looking
at local unit tests.
So these are tests
that are executed
on your local
developer's workstation
on the local VM running there.
And because you don't need to
run the entire Android build
chain--
you avoid dexing and packaging
and installing on a device--
these tests are actually
really, really fast.
On these kind of tests, you can
use a tool like Roboelectric,
which comes with its
own set of testing APIs
for setting up the state of
your Android environment,
or you can use a
tool like Mockito
and you can stub
out the interactions
with the Android framework.
Either way, they allow
you to write tests,
setting up the state
of the environment that
satisfy the
preconditions that you
might want in your test case.
The second kind of tests
are instrumentation tests.
Now, these are the
tests that will run
on a virtual or real device.
A real device could just
be a phone connected
to your workstation or it
could be a farm of devices
somewhere in the cloud.
These kind of tests
run slower because you
have to execute the whole
build chain and install
an application onto
the device, but they
have the advantage
of being a lot more
accurate because the
real or virtual device is
very similar, or in some
cases, identical to devices
that your users will be
using out in the field.
And this brings
you the confidence
that your app is going
to behave as you expect.
One criticism we have heard is
that on these kinds of tests,
there's actually a lack
of testing APIs available,
which makes it difficult
for you to set up
the state of your environment
in a way that satisfies
certain preconditions or edge
cases that you might want
to be testing.
And so we've heard
you loud and clear,
and this is something
we're actively working on.
So a bit of a little
history lesson.
In 2017 at Google
I/O, we presented
what we called the
Android testing story.
So it was based loosely around
the software development
pyramid.
And in this model,
we encouraged you
to write lots and lots of
fast, scalable unit tests
that test all your
exhaustive conditions.
We encouraged you
to write a smaller
number of instrumentation
tests that will actually
prove that all these
units assembled together
behave as you would
expect on a real device.
And in some ways, this
was kind of a compromise.
It was a compromise between the
advantages of one kind of test
and the trade-offs of another.
So it brings you a holistic
way of testing your app.
And we showed how
this kind of approach
can lead to test trim
development on Android.
First of all, you would
start with a failing UI test.
This would be an instrumentation
test, probably written
with Espresso, and it would
test the UI of your component--
your feature.
And then you would satisfy that
feature by a series of units--
classes-- coming together
with their interactions.
And you could test
drive these, as well,
using a tool like
Roboelectric or Mockito
running as a local
test, and this gives you
very fast development cycles.
Finally, when you bring
them all together,
you're able to run the slower
running, but more faithful
instrumentation test, and
hopefully, it goes green
and you're done.
Well, we enter a
refactoring cycle
because maybe your code
leaves a little to be desired
and you want to do some cleanup.
So you can spend some
refactoring cycles there,
before coming around to the
beginning of the cycle, where,
if you have any more
work on the feature,
you might add another test--
test another aspect
of that feature--
and you'll keep iterating until
you're complete, at which time,
you're good to submit your code
and move on to the next task.
So at Google I/O this year,
we realized there was somewhat
of a test writing crisis.
And because there's so
many tools available,
it's not always clear
which one to use.
And each of these tools all
have their own different styles
and APIs and paradigms
for the same concepts
that exist on Android.
And the problem with
this is that tests
written at different levels
are not portable across levels.
Your test is kind of stuck.
It's coupled to the testing
tool and the environment
that you've written it on.
So this year at Google
I/O, we announced
a beta of AndroidX Test.
It brings testing as
a first class citizen
as part of the tool
chain, as part of Jetpack.
And we include some of
the existing libraries
you've used before, some new
APIs, full Kotlin support,
which allows you to write really
beautiful and concise tests,
and it's available
on and off device.
Well, last week, AndroidX
Test moved out of beta,
into the first full
and final release--
1.0.
It's also, as of last
week, fully open sourced,
so we look forward to
welcoming your contributions.
And all of the documentation
on developer.Androi
d.com/training/testing has
all been revamped to show you
the new styles of APIs.
So please go and check that out.
So let's take a look inside.
The first module
that we pulled across
was the existing
JUnit for support--
the runner and the rules that
you may have used before.
We've also added a new
module, which we call Core,
and this includes some new APIs.
ApplicationProvider--
as its name
suggests, it's a
quick and easy way
to get a hold of the
application context.
ActivityScenario, which
is a brand new API that
provides coarse and fine
grained APIs for which
you can test your activities.
And FragmentScenario, which
was released, actually,
just this week, providing a
very similar set of testing
features for fragments.
We've also brought Espresso into
the Jetpack AndroidX family.
Espresso, if you're
not aware, is a library
with a set of view matching
APIs and a set of view actions.
So it'll allow you to match
and then interact with those UI
elements.
It also includes some other
things like the ability
to capture and stub
intents for the system.
And finally, we've also released
some Truth Android extensions.
And Truth is Google's
open-source fluent testing
sessions library,
and we've brought
in a bunch of components
for Android subjects,
which allow you to
test your Android
objects in a way that reads
beautifully and concisely.
Those of you who've been
using Roboelectric will
know that we've had a version--
4.0-- in beta for a while.
And as of last week, we
did a simultaneous release.
That's now gone into final.
Roboelectric 4 fully supports
all of the unified APIs
that are in AndroidX
Test, as well as
a number of its own new
features and improvements.
OK.
And so I'd like to
welcome Yuki on stage.
He's going to give you
a deeper dive into some
of the APIs available.
Yuki?
[APPLAUSE]
Here you go.
YUKI HAMADA: Thanks.
Thanks, Jonathan.
Hi, everyone.
So let me introduce
our new APIs.
Let's start with
ApplicationProvider,
which is a new way of accessing
context from your test board.
So when you work
on Android testing,
you need to handle two
different context objects.
The first one comes from
application under your test
and the second one comes
from the instrumentation APK,
where your test code is stored.
So with today's library, we
have two different methods
to access this context object,
and this makes your test code
harder to understand
because the library uses
library static terminology.
Target context means context
from your instrumentation APK,
while--
sorry.
The target context means the
context from your application,
while get context
means the context
from your instrumentation APK.
Also, it is not obvious which
one to use for your test.
So in our new API, we hide
the instrumentation context
from public API, and
ApplicationProvider only
provides our application context
in the form of your application
graph.
Let's take a look
at the example code.
So here, let's say we have a
test for the location tracker
activity, and in
the setup method,
we get the target context
in the old fashioned way,
and we typecast it to our
location tracker application
so that we can register our
mock object for testing.
And second line, set the
mock object for that.
And this code is pretty
simple and it actually works,
but you could have
used a wrong context
and faced a runtime
error and ended up
with wasting your
time for debugging.
Now, with the new way,
application context provider
provides your context in
your application graph,
so you can do the
exact same thing,
but there is much less
chance for confusion or bugs.
OK.
Let me move onto the
more complicated stuff--
ActivityScenario.
Actually, before we
dive into details,
I have a few questions for you.
How many of you have
written your own activity
and handled the lifecycle
transition by yourself?
Please raise your
hand if you are.
Cool.
And how many of you have
shipped your activity
with a nig related
to life cycles?
Oh, many of you.
And who didn't like
the test for that?
Who did not like the test?
Cool.
Well, yeah.
I see some hands
up-- keeping up.
And to be honest, I did, too.
And I agree.
The writing test for the
activity life cycle transition
is pretty hard, and
there is no such good API
in our testing library as now.
So that's why me and
Jonathan and our team
have sought for a
solution, and we developed
the ActivityScenario,
which-- you can use it
for driving your activity
state to an arbitrary
state for testing.
So let's revisit the
activity state first.
So the created state is
when activity is created--
I mean, instantiated-- but it
is not visible to users yet,
or activity can be
created state while it is
running in background, as well.
And the started state
is when activity
is created and started.
It's partially visible to
users, but not the foreground
activity.
Activities running in picture
mode are also in this state.
And the resumed state
is where your activity
is fully visible to users
and running in foreground.
And under the framework-- can
change the life cycle state
by any time by the
user interactions,
so your activity has
to handle those state
transitions properly for
a good user experience.
Otherwise, you'll see some bugs.
And the ActivityScenario
provides a method move
to state, which you can drive
your activity's life cycle
state to an arbitrary
state for testing.
Let's take a look
at the example code.
Here, we have our test for
our location tracker activity,
and here, we want to verify
that the location listener is
properly unregistered
from the system
when the activity
becomes a created state.
So at first, we have
this start activity.
Launch activity takes your
activity graph and start
activity, and waits for it
until it becomes resumed state.
And move to state initiates
that life cycle transition
and moves the life cycle
state to the created state.
Also, the older
ActivityScenario method
works as a blocking code.
So after this method
go, it is guaranteed
that the activity's life
cycle state-- to be created.
And then you can inspect your
activity's internal state
by coding own activity method.
Yes, that's easy.
Now we have our API.
And also, you can
use ActivityScenario
for testing the creation
of your activity.
So activity recreation
happens when your activity
is running in background
for a long time
and when you come back later.
And your activity has to
save its internal state
to a saved instance
state bundle before it
is destroyed, otherwise,
you will lose the state.
And ActivityScenario
has a method--
recreate-- where you can use
it for testing such a scenario.
Let's see the example code.
So here in this test,
we want to make sure
that input text is restored
properly after the activity is
recreated after destruction.
So first, we have some test
data like test user as an input,
and again, we start
activity, and then
we fill a text box by
using the Espresso library.
As you can see, the
ActivityScenario
works pretty nicely
with Espresso,
and then we code recreate, which
actually destroys the activity
and recreates a new instance
and waits for the activity
to be resumed state.
And then, again, using
your Espresso again,
we can make sure that the
text is there, as we expected.
Yes, it's all so simple.
Finally, I'd like to show you
one more example from the Truth
extension.
Intent subject-- by
use of intent subject,
you can verify
your intent values,
and it produces really
good human friendly error
messages if the error happens.
Let's see an example code.
In this time, we
want to, again, make
sure our data intent has an
expected contact name in it--
extra.
So first, we create a
bundle of the data intent,
and then we assert
by three lines.
One is checking if that
intent has expected actions,
and the second one is
type, and the third one
is the extra bundles.
And if the value doesn't
match your expectation,
you see this error.
As you can see,
you can immediately
know in this example,
the intent action
is not what you expected.
And [INAUDIBLE] component
come with AndroidX Test 1.0.
I can't show you
everything today,
but for example, we
have more assertions
and we also have
Android builders
where you can create
your testing data easily.
And also, scenarios for
activity and fragments, and you
can take a look at this link
or documentation to see more.
I hope you do try it
out after the talk.
OK.
So this is our solution for
the test writing crisis.
So with unified
API, you no longer
consider whether to
write an instrumentation
test or the Roboelectric test
because you can now just write
an Android test,
and that test runs
on both runtime
environments nicely.
So with the unified API, you
can focus on what to test
and you can forget
about where and how.
And to ensure the
consistency of the behavior
of our API, we have
a verification test,
and we run the same
test against the--
sorry.
We run the same test
locally with Roboelectric,
and also, we run our
test on virtual devices,
from the API level 15
to the latest version.
And let's go back to the
workflow we showed you
earlier in this talk.
So we can execute the
test driven development
much more efficiently
using the device agnostic
test with the data test
writing in a unified API.
As our recommendation,
we recommend
that you write the test and
run the test with Roboelectric,
until your code is ready
to submit, and then
run the same test, but
on the virtual devices
before actually you submit
the test to maximize
your confidence.
Also, you can run the same test
as a continuous integration
test against the
[INAUDIBLE] binaries.
With the upcoming Nitrogen
[? two ?] [? chains, ?] you can
set up such a
configuration easily.
If you want to know more
about the Project Nitrogen,
we have a session
tomorrow, and we highly
recommend attending it.
Cool.
Thank you very
much for listening,
and have a happy testing.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]